Glanz und Brecht
[Musik]
schönen guten Morgen Richard guten
Morgen Markus immer erste Folge im neuen
Jahr und drei König heute sechster
Januar 6 Januar ja Leute dir was drei
König
die heilige Könige
für mich zu den schönen Geschichten
meiner Kindheit also ich konnte man sich
immer so hübsch vorstellen
an den Krippen rum und so weiter ja und
dass die wenigsten Menschen wissen ne
kommen aber in der Bibel nicht vor na
sind in keinem Evangelium sondern
stammen aus dem Mittelalter als Könige
im Matthäus Evangelium tauchen sie
natürlich als Sterndeuter auf als Weise
aus dem Morgenland
und wie wir alle wissen sind die
Evangelien die vier Evangelien für vier
verschiedene Kulturkreise geschrieben
und das Matthäusevangelium für den
persischen Kulturkreis und da gab es die
Religion des zu oberasrismus des ewigen
Kampfes von Gut gegen Böse das ist das
Thema ist sowas astrismus und die Sterne
stehen eine große Rolle bei den Personen
kein Wunder dass die Sterndeuter dann zu
Jesus kommen wäre super ich ich kenn das
doch nicht Sternsinger und so weiter
kennst du das aus deiner Kindheit oder
haben die Sternsinger aber um euch als
bekennen kommunistischen Haushalten
großen Bogen gemacht nee das war ja
nicht ein roter Stern an der Tür die die
jetzt angehalten hätte und die die dann
dagegen irgendein goldenen Stern
ausgewechselt hätten
das heißt
kein Spruch in diesem Haus sind
Sternsinger unerwünsche
nein nein meine Eltern hatten ja waren
ja sehr aufgeschlossen gegenüber
Religion also für Piraten haben wir alle
eine gute religiöse Bildung wir fangen
ich war ja sogar in der evangelischen
Jungschar wirklich ja ich war mal
Sternsinger weißt du das ich habe das
mal gemacht selber okay wann unterwegs
das falle ich immer großartig wo wollen
wir relativ jung so 13 14 15 damals
wolltest du doch auch noch Musiker
werden oder ja ja und dann und dann
haben wir da gesungen und so weiter und
das lustige war ein sehr netter Mann aus
unserem Dorf der Sepp hat uns dann
rumgefahren ja wir waren ja alle sehr
Kleinert alle keinen Führerschein die
die Sternsinger die Erwachsenen hatten
keine Zeit das zu machen wir haben das
dann gemacht und dann sind wir so schön
verkleidet und sind dann rumgefahren
worden von Haus zu Haus und dann
wirklich von Berg zu Berg und dann wenn
es dann richtig weit hoch gehen in die
abgelegenen Höfe
Schneeketten anlegen und so weiter und
ich fand das immer ganz faszinierend
weil wir natürlich in jedes Haus
reingekommen sind auch in die teuren
Ferienhäuser deutscher Touristen und so
weiter und konnten da mal sehen wie es
da drin aussieht das war irgendwie schön
das klingt nach Kindheit aus dem
Bilderbuch also wenn ich nicht wüsste
das ist doch irgendwie bitte Arm warst
und so weiter ja aber es ist
Tirol erzählt ja hat das sowas sowas von
von Kinderbuch das meine ich irgendwie
wünschen ohne Kindheit hätte ich auch
gerne gehabt aber wirklich sowas ist
also es war genauso dolomitisches
Bullerbü irgendwie ja ja auf eine Art
war es das tatsächlich das war sehr
unbeschwert und im Grunde es war völlig
okay wenig Geld zu haben weil alle
hatten wenig Geld und deswegen war das
auch kein Problem aber es war sehr
inspirierend und wir waren dafür ja wir
waren für uns inspiriert und von guten
Lehrern von von von Freunden werden
wahnsinnig schöne Kindheit auf einer Art
ist wirklich so und viel draußen und
dann dieses dieses unmittelbare Erleben
von Winter und so mitzukriegen wie die
Leute reagieren
immer die Frage die die guten Leute
waren die wo wir besonders viele Keks
und guten Tee bekommen haben was würdest
du sagen hat dieses Erleben von echt im
Winter also nicht von so einem Hamburger
Matsch Regen Winter ja sondern vom dol
kritischen Puderzucker Winter was hat
das mit dir gemacht meinst das kindliche
gemütlich in irgendeiner Form geformt ja
extrem ich ich weiß du das für mich also
in eine Welt zu kommen oder mit meine
ich jetzt speziell Norddeutschland ja
die sozusagen unter anderem dadurch
gekennzeichnet ist das ist so was wie
Jahreszeiten eigentlich gar nicht so
richtig gibt
zumindest nicht in einem vollständigen
Sinne so wie ich das kannte es hat mich
wahnsinnig irritiert und umgekehrt wurde
mir dadurch erstmal klar wie sehr das
prägt nirgendwo gibt es so klar
ausgeformte Jahreszeiten wie dort in den
Dolomiten es gibt es gibt diesen würde
ich sagen die Landschaft in den
Dolomiten einen religiös macht
oder zumindestens spiritueller als wenn
man im Jahr groß wird also ja also
spiritueller definitiv ich meine es gibt
ja es gibt dort diese diese ganze
wunderbare Sagenwelt ja allein nur die
vorstellst die Idee die Geschichte die
ich als Kind immer gelesen und gehört
habe ja warum sind die Dolomiten so hell
ist ja ganz helles schönes Gestein und
dann gibt es diese Vollmond Nächte im
Winter in den Dolomiten glasklar kalt
der funkeln Sterne im Himmel so was hast
Du noch nicht gesehen ja und dann ist da
diese Ruhe und das mit der Vollmond dann
rauskommt dann glitzert diese ganze Welt
es ist wunderschön diese diese magische
Nächte das macht einen an Dich das macht
eigentlich für große pathetische
Stimmungen noch nicht mal es macht Dich
empfänglich für Fantasie es ist es ist
bereichert deine Fantasie es gibt zum
Beispiel die schöne Geschichte der
Mondprinzessin ja also die
Mondprinzessin heiratet an den Prinzen
aus den Dolomiten
und weil sie den Mond so vermisst ja und
weil er sie auf der anderen Seite so
sehr liebt ja beauftragter irgendwann
eine eine Weberin und sagt pass auf wir
spinnen jetzt aus dem Mondlicht spinnen
wir silberne mondlichtfäden und die und
und wir spinnen so viele davon dass wir
die gesamten Dolomiten die hat damit
überziehen können und dadurch schimmern
die Dolomiten so so so hell und so
wunderschön in diesen Vollmond Nächten
ja und das führt dazu dass die
Mondprinzessin weniger Heimweh hat ja
und deswegen heißen die Dolomiten auch
die gleichen Berge und das sind halt so
schöne Geschichten die haben uns alle
wahnsinnig inspiriert oder die
Geschichte von dem Grafen von dem Grafen
Prag der immer zu seiner Geliebten in
ein anderes Teil der Richtung Cortina
geritten ist los reitend in Bruneck da
in der Gegend in Reichard und dann
natürlich überfallen wird und verfolgt
wird von irgendwelchen Unholden Räubern
ja die im Wald ihr Unwesen treiben und
irgendwann Säbeln die einfach so eine
Brücke über so eine spektakuläre Coach
Säbeln die einfach ab damit sie ihn
jetzt endlich meine Ruhe ausrauben
können so und dann ist da dieser Graph
ja der Pack und dann gibt es dieses
schwarze Pferd ja du ahnst wie die
Geschichte weitergeht er ahnt die Falle
ja und merkt oh Mist die haben diese
Brücke weggesäbelt und dann flüstert er
seinem Pferd irgendwas ins Ohr und der
springt mit einem gigantischen Satz über
diese wahnsinnige Schlucht ja wenn sie
vorstellen wir uns das immer inspiriert
hat ja das funktioniert auch ich kenne
die Geschichte von Karl Mayer
springt er doch mit riesen nur so eine
Schlucht ich wusste gar nicht dass er
das sozusagen
aber wenn ich interessant finde ist mich
fragt die dich immer so sagt ein
religiösen Empfindungen weil ich mir
eine Frage stelle mir die Frage sind
religiöse Menschen eigentlich gelassener
als Atheisten
das kann ich also im Vergleich nicht
bewerten aber ich finde das also
religiöse Menschen die wirklich an etwas
glauben und damit ja auch meist an einen
Weiterleben nach dem Tod die sind vor
allen Dingen im Angesicht des Todes
total gelassen und wenn ich mir die
Grundhaltung meiner Mutter zum Beispiel
ansehe eine tiefgläubige Bergbau und
Tochter also so viel Gelassenheit werde
ich in meinem Leben nie hinkriegen wie
wie meine Mutter sehen sich getragen hat
und das ist ja schon interessant ich
habe das Gefühl dass es eine große
Sehnsucht nach Gelassenheit gibt und
lass es uns sagen es ist nur die letzten
Jahre waren ja auch in der einzige
Ansammlung von Katastrophen ich habe
überhaupt nicht das Gefühl den
gelassenen Zeiten zu leben aber ich habe
das Gefühl dass die Sehnsucht
nachgelassen so wahrscheinlich selten so
selten Augenblick ja genau und ich habe
ich habe dieser Tage von Leon windscheid
in den du auch kennst der immer wieder
tolle Sachen sagt zu dem Thema psychol
teuer der sagte drei Dinge machen uns
Angst dass Unbekannte das unerwartete
und das unkontrollierbare so und jetzt
überleg mal legt das mal drüber so als
Schablone es ist exakt das was wir in
den letzten Jahren ja erlebt haben aber
weißt du was ich dazu geführt sagen
würde das macht uns heute Angst das sind
Dinge die haben deiner Mutter mit ihrer
Gelassenheit wahrscheinlich weniger
Angst gemacht wir leben heute in einer
Welt gerade in der digitalen Welt in der
wir in dem wahren Leben alles
kontrollieren zu können zu wollen und so
sollen und wenn es dann nicht gelingt
dann ist es unglaublich frustrierend
wenn man aber so die Einstellung hat
meine Hand liegt in Gottes Schicksal
nein mein Schicksal liegt in Gottes Hand
wenn man sagt dass man dann natürlich
eine andere Art von Gelassenheit hat und
dass die Tatsache dass man nicht alles
kontrollieren kann dann gar nicht so
schlimm ist
ja aber wenn man das Gefühl hat ja der
Herrgott nimmt der Herrgott Gips und so
weiter dann ist ja was anderes als wenn
man das Gefühl hat man könnte mit Hilfe
von Technik oder so sich gegen alle
Risiken immunisieren unser Leben
vorausplanen und künstliche Intelligenz
rechnet einem die Todes
Wahrscheinlichkeit beim Bergsteigen aus
und was was ich was alles und so also
wir kommen hier in einer Welt in der wir
das
unkontrollierbare immer weniger zulassen
genau deswegen leiden wir darunter weil
die Menschen hatten über tausende von
Jahren das große Problem dass sie vor
lauter Dingen umgeben waren die sie
nicht vorhersehen konnten die unbekannt
waren die unerwartet waren und
unkontrollierbar und das waren nicht
ihre größten Sorgen das stimmt also
genau das Gegenteil von dem was
windscheißer was heute unsere größten
Songs sind gelassenheit ist ja ein
riesen Thema du kennst Wilhelm Schmied
ne
Philosophen ich habe mich vor Jahren mal
mit dem über dessen schönes unterhalten
Gelassenheit das heißt auch genauso und
er sagt gelassenheit ist das was wir
gewinnen wenn wir älter werden
nicht jeder nicht finde ich auch viele
werden wütend wütend ja genau und
frustriert und verbittert und genau das
ist alles was was ich also verbittert
und gelassen zugleich kann man nicht
sein Rechner verbittert sind die die das
mit der Gelassenheit nicht hingekriegt
haben
ja also ich würde mal sagen so von der
Werkseinstellung her ist meine
Gelassenheit recht groß ja aber nicht in
jeder Lebenssituation also da kann ich
auch mit lässigen sagen wer über
bestimmte Dinge den verstanden ich
verliert hat keinen zu verlieren also
ich kann nachweislich wütend werden ja
und sehr ungelassen werden aber so sagen
wir mal so die grundgemütsstimmung die
würde ich als recht gelassen bezeichnen
und bei dir
also ich habe schon das Gefühl dass das
mit mit dem älter werden wobei er will
er im Schmied wenn wenn man das mal
liest ist ganz interessant oder er sagt
das beginnt so mit mit 60 ja das dauert
noch ein bisschen bis du diese ganz
ruhige Phase kommt und dann mit 70 und
so weiter wird sie immer besser aber ich
habe schon das Gefühl dass man
gelassener wird weil man natürlich Dinge
immer wieder erlebt hat weil man
bestimmte Situationen hat die sich dann
wiederholen und man man man man man
weiß okay muss da habe ich so schon
gesehen und am besten reagierst du jetzt
einfach so und so darauf
existenzielle Kampf ja den den ich so
ein Beginn meines Lebens dann doch hatte
der ist dann einfach irgendwann vorbei
und es ist und es ist dieses gute Gefühl
dass man es irgendwie als eigener Kraft
gepackt hat weißt du was mir auffällt
ich war mich manchmal gibt's ein
Zusammenhang sozusagen zwischen
Geld und Gelassenheit und ich würde
sagen nein ich liebe immer wieder Leute
genau wie die sehr vermögende Leute sind
so um wirklich reiche Erben wirklich
reiche Leute aber gelassen sind die
nicht da ist überall so eine
Unzufriedenheit darunter und denke mal
mein Gott noch mal was ist denn jetzt
dein Problem und ich frage mich manchmal
ob diese Gelassenheit sozusagen auch
resultiert das ist auch eine
Theorie die man diesbezüglich dann öfter
mal hört ich glaube es gibt ein
Zusammenhang zwischen Arbeit und
Gelassenheit also dieses so habe ich das
auf der Fahrt du du strengst dich sehr
an du arbeitest viel und gehst dann auch
mal über so eine Grenze hinaus und und
bis zu total Erschöpfung aber dann hast
du etwas gepackt mal funktioniert nicht
mal funktioniert aber auch und wenn es
funktioniert
resultiert daraus so eine tiefe innere
zu fahren
genau aber egal woher kommt ist mir dann
wurscht aber ich nehme es trotzdem
es kommt nicht vom Serotonin sondern
weil du gelassen des schüttest du
Serotonin aus also es ist schon ja ja
auf jeden Fall ist aber die verinnere
Zufriedenheit die man eben für Geld
nicht kaufen kann die kommt weil man
vielleicht an selbst gestecktes Ziel
erreicht hat weil man sieht dass ich so
die große lebenspart dann doch irgendwie
einigermaßen funktioniert hat und
ehrlich gesagt bei mir ich merke das
auch weißt du meinen Vater sehr früh
verstorben also in meinem Leben Alter
jetzt war mein Vater schon tot und
allein die schlichte Tatsache bis
hierhin überlebt zu haben ist etwas was
mich mit einer gewissen Demut und auch
Zufriedenheit erfüllt wirklich ganz
Platz so gesagt
also ich glaube dass das was du bei dir
beschreibst dass das oft gibt aber es
gibt auch andere Menschen es gibt schon
im Studium Menschen kennengelernt die
eine verblüffende Gelassenheit hatten
und obwohl sie nicht ausreichen Eltern
kamen und auch nicht so richtig wussten
was aus ihrem Leben wird und so weiter
doch immer sehr entspannt fahren auch
nicht sehr viel Ehrgeiz hatten
und die deswegen aber nicht unzufriedene
Menschen geworden sind dass sie jeder
hat ja auch eine unterschiedliche Dosis
ne an eher geil die man erreichen will
und so bei manchen ist das ja schnell
erreicht also da reicht ein gutes
Fußballspiel oder ein Bier und so weiter
aus ja oder netter Abend mit Freunden ne
und man ist man ist wirklich zufrieden
also das sind Menschen sehr sehr sehr
unterschiedlich das ist nicht so
richtiges Erfolgsrezept für Gelassenheit
weil es gibt auch andere Menschen die
ganz hart arbeiten so wie du das gerade
geschrieben hast bei denen sich trotzdem
nicht das Gefühl der Gelassenheit
einstellt sondern das Gefühl und jetzt
was ist der nächste Schritt also es gibt
Menschen die kommen aus diesem getrieben
seinsmodus nicht raus guck mal wir haben
uns unlängst über ihn und Maske
unterhalten ja und der ist für mich
nicht der Inbegriff der Gelassenheit wo
man ja sagen könnte doch der hat ja
viele Leiste muss ich keine Sorgen
machen Geldautomaten geht dass die Karte
nicht mehr rauskommt und so ne und
trotzdem nicht das Gefühl dass
Gelassenheit jetzt die Qualität ist die
in am stärksten aus ja erinnerst du dich
es diese Szene auch schon letztes Jahr
Fußball WM Katar Ronaldo schießt
angeblich vermeintlich die Aktoren
und lässt sich feiern bis zum geht
unvorstellbar wer weiß doch ganz genau
dass er nichts davon berührt hat und
schon gar nicht den Ball ja also mit
diesem Tor nichts zu tun aber es war ein
unfassbar wichtig klar zu mal so ich war
das jetzt ja das ist doch das krasse
Gegenteil von Gelassenheit und ich habe
gedacht was ist das für ein Mensch
gelassen war der andere der Ronaldo in
aller Ruhe lassen obwohl er insgeheim
wusste dass er eigentlich das Tor
geschossen hat ist das irre oder aber
erklär mir das mal woher kommt das
jemand der so viel erreicht hat der auch
so viel Geld verdient hat der so viel
Erfolg hatte dem dem Millionen Menschen
einfach zu Füßen wegen dem alles zu
gelingen sein und dann hast du diesen ja
dann Verbissenheit natürlich diesen
Ehrgeiz und dann musste jetzt auch
dieses Tor muss jetzt noch da sein weil
sonst kannst du nachts nicht schlafen
mehr vielleicht ist hat er ja unter
anderem diese Karriere gemacht weil er
von diesem brennenden Ehrgeiz besiedelt
war und das Problem ist ja der lässt ja
nicht im gleichen Maße nach wie deine
fußballerischen Fähigkeiten du bleibst
ja genau der gleiche Mensch nur die
Anzahl der Erfolgserlebnisse dünnt sich
aus und hast bei Fußball ja verrückt ist
ne du kannst bis 35 36 bist du
Weltklasse ja und innerhalb von 1 2 3
Jahren ja nimmt dich kein Ende der
zweiten Liga mehr also das ist ja
absolut verrückt das zu sehen und das
wird natürlich mit Ronaldos Psyche eine
ganze Menge machen und ich glaube jemand
der so eine Psyche hat der wird egal in
welchem Alter er ist nicht gelassen
werden das kann nur ein großes Drama
werden also irgendwann musst du für dich
ja eine Umgang einen Umgang damit finden
ne wenn du den nicht findest wirst
schwierig ich jetzt sag mal kann uns
wenn man über Gelassenheit spricht ne
dann denkt man als jemand der mal auf
einem humanistischen Gymnasium war das
erste was du denkst sind Stoiker mag
ist und es gibt ja so ein richtiges
Revival ne von von ja ja
ja ja genau also es ist sozusagen die
modephilosophie unserer Zeit ja stolika
es gibt sozusagen so best of Anthologien
oder Stoiker einfach erklärt und so
weiter ich sehe das mit dem lachenden
Auge also dass das Lachen
26 April 121 nach Christus in Rom
geboren
genau
und ähm ist da in germanienfeld so
blutig dreckig so wie man den aus
Gladiator kennt der hatte keinen keinen
gelassenes Leben ne überhaupt nicht und
angeblich hat er dann ja da in Germanien
hinter der Front ja in aller Ruhe dieses
Büchlein geschrieben dass ein zeitloser
Klassiker geworden ist und in dem alle
Weisheiten der Gelassenheit drin stehen
der Toleranz
der der der der der
Feindesliebe der Achtung vor dem anderen
und das Buch steht in keinerlei
Zusammenhang zu seiner Rolle als Kaiser
also er ist auch berüchtigter
Christenverfolger gewesen ja also es ist
absolute Gegenteil von Toleranz und ich
frage mich natürlich seit ich das am
ersten Mal in den Fingern hatte hat
dieser Mann dieses Buch geschrieben also
wir werden es nie überprüfen können ich
halte es für extrem unwahrscheinlich
extrem unwahrscheinlich ich glaube nicht
also er war sicher gebildet diese
berühmten Selbstbetrachtung
gehabt der das dann aus Marketing
Gründen da irgendwie geschrieben hat das
ist jetzt natürlich ein böser Verdacht
und mag auch hier kann sich dagegen
nicht mehr wehren ja aber so richtig
vorstellen dass er der Uhr hier bei
dieser dieses Text ist es ist an dieser
dieser wirklich weisen Betrachtung wo
Einsatz schöner ist als ja andere ja
vorstellen kann ich mir das nicht also
ich sag nicht es war nicht so ne weil
das können wir nicht überprüfen aber das
Urheberrecht war in der Antike nicht das
gleiche wie heute ich könnte viele
Beispiele von von von Texten also ob
Caesar den den gallischen Krieg da
selbst den Bello gallikum selbst
verfasst hat oder ob er den diktiert hat
oder ob der sinngemäß im Gesprächen
geschrieben wurde so wie heute Politiker
sich ihre Bücher schreiben lassen und
das berühmteste Beispiel ja der
berühmteste Mathematiker der Antike
ja wo die gesammelte mathematische
Weisheit der Antike drin ist in dem Buch
von Euklid ist höchstwahrscheinlich
nicht mal eine Person gewesen sondern
eine Gruppe eine
sozusagen genau da wurde eine Menge
zusammengetragen da hat man sozusagen
das ganze Wissen der der Antike in eine
Schriftrolle gebracht und hat nachher
Namen drauf geschrieben vielleicht den
Namen von jemanden der tatsächlich mal
irgendwie existiert hat um mal was für
ein Watte zu tun hatte vielleicht auch
eine erfunden haben
immer so bei diesen Texten nicht so ganz
ganz sicher also man mag auch irgendwie
nicht mehr überhaupt nicht sicher das
ist aber egal
genau und die Parallelen also ich glaube
das ist eine der Gründe für diese
Wiederentdeckung und diesen erfolgt der
Stoiker ist ist genau das also Marc
Aurel Kriege geführt Missernten ich
meine wir reden auch über Missernten
mittlerweile Klimaveränderung wir reden
über die Kornkammer Deutschlands rund um
Magdeburg wo es auch nicht mehr richtig
regnet und die Frage was wäre irgendwann
mal essen werden das das wird ein Thema
werden definitiv und dann noch in der
Zeit auch interessant über 20 Jahre
hinweg eine Pandemie der Millionen
Menschen zum Opfer gefallen sind damals
antoninische Pest glaube aber Pocken war
nicht die beste sondern eher ein Pocken
Erreger aber ich sag mal die Parallelen
zur heutigen Zeit sind ja die sind ja
sowas von augenscheinlich und
frappierend
[Musik]
ja und deswegen also nach wie vor dir
der Verdacht dass das nicht aus des
Kaisers Hand stammt aber interessant ist
auch wenn wir wenn wir heute dieses
Story currywival haben ich finde das
immer wahnsinnig schön wenn Menschen
sich mit abendländischer Philosophie
beschäftigen was wir hatten so viele
Jahrzehnte da haben die Leute immer so
fernöstliche Weisheiten in der Familie
zu sich genommen oder vielleicht auch
die ein oder andere katholischen
Sinnspruch ja aber dass man sich die
Arbeit macht und sich hier richtig
wieder in die Philosophie der
eigentlichen einarbeitet finde ich super
ja das weinende Auge ist natürlich so
ein bisschen da wird er jetzt schon
Auflauf draus gemacht ja also so wie man
die alle lateinamerikanischen Tänze in
seiner Eindampfen kann
man natürlich jetzt auch sowieso mit
Gebrauchs Store erfinden und dann darf
man nicht vergessen das war eine
Philosophie in einer ganz bestimmten
Zeit mit einer sagen wir mal
problemlösungsfunktion die völlig anders
ist als heute es war nicht so ähnlich
wie heute also die storiker beginnen als
Kommunisten
interessanterweise ohne Zenon ja also wo
es heißt dass man so als gleich wichtig
das Schaf in der Herde Leben soll und
solche Scherzchen man weiß über diesen
Menschen sehen und auch nichts außer
komische Anekdoten aber der der Anfang
des historikertums hatte nichts mehr mit
dem zu tun was ist nachher bei den
Römern war bei den Römern war das so was
wie inoffizielle Staatsreligion das war
so die die Weltanschauung des Imperiums
und da hatten einige clevere Griechen
die Griechen sind ja von den Römern
einkassiert worden und die
Intellektuellen sind dann zum Teil nach
oben gegangen und haben da die Römer
unterrichtet die Römer waren ja
kulturloses Bauern Volk im Grunde
genommen Soldaten Volk und haben Ihnen
dann die ganze Zeit geschmeichelt ja ähm
wie großartig hier Imperium ist und so
weiter und dann wurde der suizismus
unter anderem zurechtfertigung des
römischen Imperiums benutzt
also das wurde dann wirklich so so für
die herrschaftselite so eine
rechtfertigungsphilosophie und wenn man
das alles so zusammenfasst was sind
sozusagen die die Dinge in der solischen
Philosophie und die überhaupt sich über
diesen langen Zeitraum von 350 400
Jahren durchhalten
dann ist natürlich Gelassenheit ganz
wichtig aber muss eins dazu sagen alle
griechische Philosophie zielte
aufgelassenheit das ist nicht typische
für Historiker Gelassenheit da gibt es
drei vier verschiedene griechische
Begriffe für das auch die die epikurea
sozusagen
Gelassenheit das Ziel
was die Suche glaubten war dass das
Leben vorher bestimmt ist und zwar in
Form eines vorher bestimmten weltenlaufs
alle 2000 Jahre verbrennt die Erde ja
kommt eine gigantische Feuerwalze und
zerstört alles und dann entsteht das
gleiche wieder neu
und wir sind nur ein kleines Rädchen im
Getriebe ja dieses fatalistischen
weltenlaufen das ist genau prägend
gewesen das heißt also die Geschichte
macht und auf einen selber kommt am Ende
nicht an daher kommt diese nimm Dich
nicht so wichtig Gelassenheit
teilen wir ja den ganzen Rest nicht mehr
wir glauben ja nicht mehr dass alle 2000
Jahre die Welt untergeht und so weiter
also der Rahmen innerhalb dessen der der
Story gelassen war nach dem Motto naja
gut ist egal die Welt geht ja sowieso
unter genau den haben wir nicht wenn man
den könnten wir heute wieder haben aber
wir wissen in 2000 Jahren gibt es keine
neue also wir können natürlich im
Horizontes Klimawandels könnten wir die
gleiche Gelassenheit an den Tag legen
aber mir ist sehr viel lieber wir würden
die Gelassenheit nicht an den Tag legen
weil wir wissen dass dann die Welt nicht
wieder neu entsteht jedenfalls nicht für
Menschen aber das heißt so ein ein dem
es mal so ein bisschen nachspürt ja man
würde ja oberflächlich betrachtet sagen
die
moderne und Alters was wir gerade auch
in den letzten Jahren Jahrzehnten so
erlebt haben das Wüten Menschen auf und
wirbelt unser Leben durcheinander und
daraus entsteht sozusagen diese
Sehnsucht nach Gelassenheit aber
offenbar fehlt uns ja noch etwas dazu
nämlich so ein gewisser Fatalismus der
ja zum Beispiel jemand wie meine Mutter
hatte auch die hätten alle ja also im
Grunde du hast das ist es eher
eigentlich alles klar und am Ende des
Lebens ist auch klar wo du hingehst also
dieses sichere gute Gefühl du gehst dann
einen im Zweifel besseren schöneren Ort
weißt du das hat sogar was animalisch
ist das ist so ein bisschen was wo man
denkt bei Tieren ist das so ja also wir
verruten ohne das zu wissen dass Tiere
sich nicht vor dem Tod fürchten wir
sehen auch wenn der wenn der Leopard
der der Antilope in den Nacken springt
ja die wehrt sich bis zu dem Moment und
wo sie weiß jetzt weißt du da hinten zu
oder ist erscheint hier irgendwie klar
zu sein dann war es das jetzt halt ja
Knick da ein und bleibt ruhig liegen
und diese dieses einbehalten sein im
Kreislauf der Natur ja der ist irgendwie
wie so ein animalisches Erbe noch sehr
sehr lange in unserer Kultur gewesen wir
sind ein Teil der Natur ja Staub bist du
zum Staub fährst du zurück was wir so
kennen oder was Prediger Salomo
abgebildet ist der Prediger Salomo aus
der Bibel ja ist von Story können
geschrieben ja der ist nicht von
religiösen Juden geschrieben sondern das
ist ein storischer Text der eingewandert
ist ja und da ist es gibt nichts Neues
unter der Sonne ja diese Vorstellung der
die ewige Wiederkehr des sinnlosen
gleichen und so das hatte ja überhaupt
nichts mit Christentum zu tun hat doch
nichts mit Judentum zu tun
das ist solche Philosophie
und das hat was von von Naturbeobachtung
weißte von von so ist das genau dieser
ewige Kreislauf der Natur dieses
einbehalten sein im Natur zusammen
machen ich glaube dass das vielleicht
bei deiner Mutter noch auch bei meinen
Großeltern so warten in den Lauf der
Dinge und heute leben wir in einer Welt
wo wir sagen nee nee nee wir sind nicht
eingehalten im Lauf der Dinge wir wollen
die Dinge gestalten wir wollen ein
Optimum an Glück und einen Sinn und für
uns und für unsere lieben und vielleicht
für die Menschheit also dieses Gefühl
wir müssen die Welt machen und nicht wir
müssen uns an die Welt anpassen und das
unterscheidet uns erst seit wenigen
Jahrzehnten
von allen Kulturen auf diesem Planeten
sind er hat es interessant das hast du
ja auch bei den bei den
inuitierern in Grönland zum Beispiel
also die da gibt da gibt es auch so ein
Text der genau in diese Richtung geht
also wir greifen niemals in den Lauf der
Dinge ein und wir tun auch nichts um den
Lauf der Dinge zu verändern wisst ihr
das krasse Gegenteil von dem was wir tun
das ist das Gegenteil von Silicon Valley
das ist das Gegenteil sozusagen der
leitideologie unserer Zeit in dem Leben
nicht sehen ja also wir sind disruptiv
für alle durchbrechen die Ordnung wir
schaffen eine neue Ordnung eine eigene
von Menschen gemacht der Ordnung
irgendwann eine von Maschinen gemacht
machte also es ist sozusagen genau das
Gegenteil
ja und im Grunde sozusagen diese Idee du
kannst alles berechnen du kannst auch
den Menschen letzten Endes berechnen und
und kannst den sozusagen ja dann auch
auf eine Art und Weise transformieren
also wenn man sich mal anschaut wenn man
so diese diese Vision sich mal
so oder ja Technologie also die Frage
kannst du immer dann dein Bewusstsein
doch nicht zu sagen Danke Gehirn einfach
eine Cloud hochladen ja und wer bist du
denn eigentlich genau
das ist es nicht na ja also wir sind
persönlich schon Menschen begegnet die
mich gefragt haben ob ich Lust hätte als
Philosoph an solchen Forschungsprojekten
teilzunehmen die ja ja die auch nicht
mehr dreistelligen Millionen Betrieben
finanziert sind also naja also es gibt
ja zwei zwei Richtungen die Optimierung
na das eines der Trans Humanismus und
das andere ist der Post Humanismus der
zwei verschiedene Sachen der Post
Humanismus träumt davon dass Menschen
irgendwann in der Lage sein werden
Computer Roboter herzustellen die
intelligenter sind als der Mensch
komplett handlungsfähig aber irrsinnig
viel intelligenter und die dann die
Mission des Menschen weiterführen können
wo der Mensch aufgrund seiner
biologischen Grenzen nicht zu in der
Lage ist zum Beispiel das ganze
Universum zu besiegeln dann würde ja die
menschliche Intelligenz die in diesen
Maschinen mal steckt und die sich dann
über künstliche Intelligenz
verselbstständigt die wäre dann der
initial Funke um das ganze Weltall mit
von Menschen geschaffenen Kreaturen zu
besiedeln wenn du hättest dann einen
super intelligenten Roboter der aber
kein Essen kann trinken kann nichts
braucht den kannst auf den Weg zum Mars
oder sonst noch viel viel weiter und
überall hin und so weiter und der der
dessen Lebensuhr läuft ja auch nicht ab
und so wir mussten
die eine Vision dass das also die
Grenzen überwunden werden die den
Menschen gegeben sind aber wir schaffen
ein neues Wesen ne ein nicht
physiologisches Wesen
und das andere ist der Transport
das heißt also die Zeit nach genau und
der Transhumanismus versucht das gleiche
mit dem Menschen also den Menschen immer
weiter zu optimieren zu optimieren und
zu optimieren dass er irgendwann
unsterblich wird dass er als auf
Datenträger geladen werden kann in
seiner ganzen Personalität und so weiter
dass er unendlich viel intelligenter ist
dass seine Aufmerksamkeit nicht
nachlässt und so das kann man betrogen
machen das kann man versuchen mit mit
Chemie chemischen Substanzen zu machen
ja ja man kann es machen indem man
versucht Menschen mit Maschinen zu
verschmelzen genau also die menschliche
Physiologie an einem Computer so
anzuschließen dass das Gehirn quasi
sich synthetisch mit der Festplatte
verschmilzt und so ähnlich und Maske ist
gehört zu dieser Sekte der tanzen das
ist das wovon erträumt genau die
thinking und so ne genau also das die
Optimierung des Menschen nicht
Überwindung des Menschen sondern die
Optimierung des Menschen ins Unendliche
und jetzt könnte ich natürlich um zum
Thema zurückzukommen sagen wieso denn
fehlt in jegliche gelassen
also warum muss der Mensch denn
eigentlich optimiert werden ja und wird
der Mensch und dieses wäre meine
wichtigste Frage glücklicher dadurch
dass ich ihn optimiere oder glauben nur
Nerds dass man glücklich wird wenn man
irgendwann auf einem Datenspeicher
weiterlebt also ich denke für deine
Mutter wäre das keine Vision gewesen
wenn man gesagt hat Mama du musst jetzt
irgendwann gehen aber es gibt eine
Chance ich könnte dich in eine Cloud
hochladen hätte sie wahrscheinlich für
sie nicht als spannende Option gesehen
aber dieser dieser dieser dieses das
finde ich ja faszinierend also
posthumanismus das kann ich mir
irgendwie vorstellen das ist aber das
ist natürlich auch Science Fiction aber
ich glaube das ist denkbar sowas und die
Frage ist ja dann was passiert wenn
diese Maschine dann irgendwann die
Weltherrschaft Unternehmen aber dieses
dieser Transhumanismus das ist ja krass
weil also was sind das dann für Wesen
also haben die dann haben die noch
Hunger haben die Durst haben die Sex
ja wahrscheinlich haben sie alles das
virtuell ja weil die Befriedigung dieser
Dinge im virtuellen Raum nicht
enttäuschungsanfällig ist man muss ja
sagen dass alles ist ja was hat man am
Anfang gesagt die Angst vor
Kontrollverlust ja ja das Bedürfnis
alles zu kontrollieren steckt ja ganz
stark dahinter und das Bedürfnis keine
negativen Erfahrungen mehr zu machen
alles was wenn du isst kannst du
theoretisch auch was essen was überhaupt
nicht schmeckt du kannst sogar was
verfaultes Essen und daran sterben wenn
du Sex hast kann der Sex gut sein aber
er kann auch weniger gut sein aber in
der virtuellen Welt wird alles das
optimiert ja er wird sozusagen total
perfekt alles und ich denke mir immer in
einer Höhle
Leben du kennst bestimmt diese die diese
ultimative glücksmaschine die Robert
Lowick sich mal ausgedacht hat
60er 70er Jahre amerikanischer Philosoph
konservativer amerikanischer Philosoph
und der sich gesagt hat wenn ich jetzt
so eine glücksmaschine gebe wo wenn man
da drin ist wenn man einsteigt da hat
man im Leben immer nur positive
Erlebnisse in allem total gut aus und
und kommt super beim anderen Geschlecht
an und man deshalb genug Geld für alles
so man kann sich jeden Wunsch erfüllen
und so weiter das einzige Seite ist ein
nicht echt ne das ist halt aber es ist
total perfekt simuliert nur wenn du dich
einmal entscheidest da reinzugehen
rauskommen sie nicht mehr also in der
muss auch da drin bleiben und dann wurde
dann häufig die Frage gestellt ja wer
würde da reinsteigen ich habe die Frage
früher mal so häufig bei Vorträgen
gestellt ich hatte mal vor
Softwareentwicklern in München kam ich
auf die Idee man so tausend IT
Spezialisten die Frage die einfach mal
diese Frage zu stellen und das waren
glaube ich nur acht von 1000 die da
reinsteigen wird das glaube ich aber ich
dachte ihr alle arbeitet aber so ein
Stück daran eine solche Welt zu
realisieren wenn auch nur in kleinen
Schritten
Wahnsinn und das ist das interessante
also ich glaube dass die die
glücksvorstellungen also das totale
Glück dass das eine nicht humane und
nicht humanistische Vision ist
das ist so ein bisschen so weißt du was
gesagt
in den entbehrungsreichen Wintern die du
in Südtirol verbracht haben und so
weiter es war doch der Kontrast es war
doch auch der Kontrast der Armut und der
Schnee glitzernde Lage und so und nur
dadurch bekam die Dinge eine Bedeutung
richtig Glück ist ein Bedeutung geknüpft
und Bedeutung ist relativ
ja das ist Wilhelm Schmied ne also der
Tod ist es erst der das Leben wertvoll
macht ja so ist das weil nur konnte des
Todes das Leben seine Bedeutung kriegt
und ich glaube dass ihre Parabel am
menschlichen Leben wäre der Überdruss
genau man müsste ziemlich viele Pillen
einschmeißen wenn man 1000 Jahre alt
wird um an diesem Überdruss nicht
zugrunde zu gehen ja das meine ich ne
also wenn du wenn du jeden Tag Kaviar
hast dann ist halt irgendwann das
butterbrotis in Session richtig das ist
genau und jeden Tag nur Glück und Erfolg
hat sehnt man sich nach leiden und
Misserfolg nein das meine ich nicht aber
ich ich also niemand niemand möchte
gerne leiden niemand möchte Misserfolg
haben niemand möchte ständig auf die
Schnauze kriegen das ist doch gar keine
Frage aber dieses dieses dieses
nochmal dieses diese tiefe innere
Befriedigung die du erlebst wenn du aus
eigener Kraft irgendwas schaffst völlig
egal welches Ziel es ist ja ob es ein
Berg ist den du besteigst ob es
irgendein berufliches Ziel ist das zu
erreichst um irgendetwas aufgeht in
deinem Leben von dem Dach so könnte so
gehen eine Farbe aber da muss viel
zusammenpassen am Ende funktioniert das
ist natürlich großartig und selbst in
der Enttäuschung also die mit der mit
der Enttäuschung mit dem misser Volk ja
mit dem mit der Abwesenheit von Glück
sozusagen umzugehen ist ein Ungeheuer
wichtiger Lernprozess ich meine du W ist
doch genau das klingt jetzt platt aber
du wächst doch genau an diesem Momenten
das ist der Moment der dich der dich
also immer immer glücklich seid immer
glücklich sein zu wollen ja ist eine
Kinderphantasie und ich glaube das
Erwachsenwerden des Lebens besteht darin
diesem Wunsch so in der Form in dieser
absoluten Form nicht mehr zu haben
und der Zustand der Gelassenheit setzt
dann ein wenn man erkennt ja das auch
bestimmte Kinder Fantasien im Leben
nicht realisierbar sind und das ist
vielleicht gut ist dass sie nicht
realisierbar sind ja es geht ja über die
Dolomiten und diese diese glitzernächte
gesprochen haben ja es gibt ja es geht
doch um Bedeutung also Dinge müssen eine
Bedeutung haben sonst sind sie
vollkommen Wertlosigkeit mal ein
wollen Urlaubsort ein ein skurriles paar
gesehen da kam ein sehr tatteriger alter
Mann der Park der mit seiner
gigantischen Yacht draußen ja
und dann kam der mit seiner ganzen
Entourage an Land und steuerte auf so
ein Restaurant zu und alle dackelten so
hinterher das war sofort klar wer da das
Alphamännchen ist nämlich dieser alte
Kreis ja mit dieser alte dieser alte
Mann dieser Kreis mit vermutlich 90
Jahren und sein als andere Hand eine
wunderschöne junge Frau und der erste
Reflex war natürlich guck mal wir
rührend er sich um seine Enkelin kümmert
stellte sich raus es war natürlich seine
seine Frau und ich sag mal so als der
Schröder sagt immer wo Geld ist kann
auch Liebe sein ich glaube das war so
ein Fall und die beiden steuerten dann
wenig später das war interessant auf so
ein Juwelierladen zu und dann standen
hier in der Kasse beobachtet weil der
großartiges Szene es war ging um die
Frage kaufen wir jetzt diesen Ring für
15000 $ oder kaufen wir diesen Ring für
und man stand schon an der Kasse und sie
hatte sich entschieden den für 15.000
Dollar zu nehmen das ist tolle Frauen
und kurz bevor eingebucht wurde in der
Kasse sagt sie angekommen ich nehme auch
den anderen den 25.000 ja und das
interessante war aber das war das
spannende dieser Sprung von 15.000 auf
25.000 löste in ihr erkennbar genau
nichts aus es war völlig egal das löste
bei ihr nichts aus es löst ja auch bei
ihm nichts aus es ist einfach bei
niemandem irgendwas aus und ich dachte
Wahnsinn dann lass es doch einfach wenn
es alles so bedeutet die nicht ja
wirklich und das fand ich interessant
weil ich dachte guck mal das Leben ist
dann irgendwann doch auch gerecht
Zufriedenheit vielleicht sogar Glück
aber eben auch gelassen als kannst du
nicht kaufen das ist etwas das hast Du
in Dir und er arbeitest Du Dir oder Du
lässt es ihm genau noch mal kurz rich
zum Schluss
Stoiker ja mag Aurel gibt es irgendeinen
Gedanken oder auch gerne zwei oder drei
von denen du sagst das ist gut das ist
allgemeingültig das hat ich glaube ich
steht in dieser Fibel von Marc Aurel
endlich nichts drin was nicht gut ist
also es ist wirklich alles gut verdammt
der hat mich gepackt der hat mich
gekriegt in es ist eigentlich am meisten
am meisten gekriegt hat ist eine
historische Weisheit die nicht von Mark
Auriel ist oder von dem der sein Buch
geschrieben hat sondern von Kiosk das
ist ein storiker über den man gar nicht
so viel weiß und er hat den Satz
geschrieben von Natur aus gibt es keine
Vaterländer genauso wenig wie es von
Natur aus
Handwerksbetriebe und
Verkaufsstände gibt
und da ist natürlich eine Menge dran das
ist so ein Satz wo ich immer denke den
hätte ich gerne über das 21 Jahrhundert
geschrieben und damit meine ich
natürlich mit diesen vaterländern nicht
dass man keine Heimat hat oder keine
Heimatgefühle oder keine Identifikation
sondern es geht darum dass die Grenzen
die gezogen worden sind dass das alles
historische Grenzen sind von den keine
einzige natürliches nirgendwo auf der
Welt und dass das uns zwar dazu bringen
kann uns gerne mit dem Land in dem wir
leben zu identifizieren aber uns
vielleicht davon abhalten sollte im
Platten Sinne stolz darauf zu sein und
zwar so stolz dass man nationalistisch
wird und dafür finde ich dass das eine
zeitlose Weisheit die jederzeit und zu
jeder Kultur gut passt und das ist wahr
dazu passt dieser Satz von okay ich trau
mich jetzt gar nicht mehr zu sagen von
Marcel aber auf jeden Fall eine ihm sehr
nahestehender intelligenter Philosoph
hat das dann wohl aufgeschrieben oder
gesagt unser Leben ist das wozu unser
Denken ist
ist natürlich wahr oder oder diese
andere diese andere sehr schöne Gedanke
so wie du dein Leben am Ende des Lebens
wünscht gelebt zu haben so kannst Du es
eigentlich auch jetzt schon Leben
natürlich ein schöner Gedanke dass ich
sehr gute Weise Gedanken im zweiten Satz
kennt man in der trivial Version von
Steve Jobs dass man jeden Tag so leben
sollte als wenn es der Letzte wäre genau
das ist ja im Grunde genommen daraus
abgeleitet und man kann daran sehen dass
all diese Weisheiten 2000 Jahre alt sind
ob sie die Menschen die sind 2000 Jahren
entsprechend weiser gemacht haben ist
dann noch mal eine andere Frage ich
finde einen anderen Satz total gut das
der ist ein bisschen das ist eine ganz
andere Ecke aber passt so gut in unsere
Zeit wenn du wüsstest aus welchem Quell
die menschlichen Meinungen und
Interessen fließen du würdest aufhören
nach dem Beifall und dem Lob der
Menschen zu streben
das ist auch total gut das ist extrem
gut ja finde ich auch passt sehr gut zu
dem Thema was wir letztens hatten als
wir über Twitter gesprochen haben genau
das ist tatsächlich deswegen einfach
wahnsinnig interessant weil man neigt ja
dazu dass die Menschen die einem recht
geben dass man die für besonders
intelligent hält ja und die die einem
widersprechen für dumm aber es kann
genauso oft umgekehrt sein ja vor allen
Dingen was da ja auch drin ist das finde
ich so gut aus welchem Quell mit dem
menschlichen Meinungen fließen also was
ist sozusagen die Motivation Motivation
ja ja klar also und häufig ist es Neid
und Miss Kunst und Helme und so weiter
und wenn das aber so ist und wenn dir
das klar ist dann musst du doch ich
musste dich auch nicht mehr anbieten ne
also das ist ja sowieso eine spezielle
Kunst die ja auch in den glücksradgebern
quasi steht sich vom Urteil anderer
Menschen unabhängig zu machen
das sagt sich so leicht weil der Mensch
ist ein soziales Tier und
unsere ganze psych frische Ausstattung
ist auf hortenverbinder ausgelegt
innerhalb derer ist eine große Rolle
spielt was wir achten was wir echten wer
einen achtet wer ein hechtet und wo man
steht sondern man muss ja eigentlich
wollen ja natürlich also wer möchte wer
möchte denn völlig ausgestoßen und
verlassen von allem sagen ja mich
interessiert das Urteil anderer nicht
also die Kunst besteht ja darin dass
Urteil anderer wahrzunehmen sich damit
zu beschäftigen aber sich nicht so nahe
gehen zu lassen dass es ein verrückt ja
also auch da ist der Mittelweg der
richtige das ist auch also auch das
steckt ja letzten Endes in diesem
Gedanken mit drin ne also diese ich
glaube so die härteste Bestrafung die
wir als Menschen erfahren können und
deswegen sind ja auch diese sozialen
Netzwerke teilweise wirklich so grausam
dann in den in ihrer Konsequenz und in
ihrem unbedingten Willen wirklich dann
zu Vernichtung von Leuten ja also die
dieses dieses Gefühl ausgestoßen zu sein
nicht mehr zur Gruppe dazu zu gehören
das ist glaube ich viel viel härter als
im Zweifel zwei Jahren Knast zu gehen ja
je nachdem bei wie immer in einem Knast
ist also in einem deutschen Knast ja
du weißt was ich meine ja ja natürlich
dieses also soziale Ächtung ist die
Höchststrafe ja das meine ich also ich
habe früher bei Vorträgen über Moral
häufig gefragt stellen sich folgende
Situation vor ich würde Ihnen jetzt weiß
ich nicht 10 20 Millionen schenken ja
die dürfen sie behalten die müssen
niemand teilen nur unter einer einzigen
Voraussetzung sie müssen in ihrem
Heimatort wohnen bleiben und ich erzähle
jedem und alle glauben das dass sie
dieses Geld mit kinderpornografieren
ja wer möchte diesen Deal eingehen das
ist ein faustischen pack den keiner
eingehen würde weil was ist denn der
Reiz wenn man viel Geld hat ja es ist
natürlich immer verbunden damit dass man
damit Anerkennung erwirtschaften wenn
die anerkennungskategorie von vorne rein
ja mit der höchste Todeszahl quasi
benannt ist
dann hat sie keinen Wert mehr also es
geht Anerkennung ist die Währungen die
es eigentlich geht ne das ist die
Währung um die es eigentlich geht es
gibt ein paar Leute bei denen der Reiz
des Geldes sich verselbstständigt wusste
tatsächlich die reine Formierung von
Zahlen ist das sind aber sehr wenige
die meisten sehr reichen Leute kamen
eigentlich ihre ganzen materiellen
Bedürfnisse erfüllt bis über erfüllt so
und dann ist es am Ende Anerkennung
sowieso die wichtigste Währung die es
unter Menschen gibt es richtig
sicher dank dir sehr dass war ein
schöneres gelassenes Gespräch ich
wünsche dir
wirklich das könnten wir alle mal so
dringend gebrauchen ne ja hoffen
gelassen ja wirklich aber ich habe das
Gefühl es wird nicht passieren und
deswegen ist es umso wichtiger dass in
uns selber zu suchen ich glaube wir
müssen unser mindset ändern wir mal
heute sagt ich glaube da hast du völlig
recht ich glaube die einzige stabile
Erwartung die wir an die Zukunft haben
können ist nicht dass die Krisen
aufhören sondern dass wir lernen
resilien umzugehen
ja und nicht nicht zu verzweifeln nicht
nicht zu verzagen nicht
ängstlich in der Ecke zu sitzen dazu
neigt dieses Land ja häufig finde ich
und ich bin aber umgekehrter Meinung das
was wir wirklich können wenn es darauf
ankommt was haben wir doch nicht mal
ansatzweise abgerufen und das ist eine
gute Nachricht ja Richard dank dir sehr
ich danke dir auch mal das nächste Woche
eine Produktion von m hoch 2 und
Popstars bei OMR im Auftrag des ZDF
[Musik]